[Musique]
le scandale chez Hockey Canada 500
gymnastes qui dénoncent le climat
toxique au sein de leur organisation des
membres de l'équipe nationale de
water-polo qui poursuivent leur
fédération pour négligence et abus des
exemples concrets qui illustrent avec
fracas l'importance d'imposer un
changement de culture au sein de
plusieurs grandes associations sportives
pour leur forcer la main
Ottawa annonçait que leur financement
serait conditionnel à ce qu'elles
adhèrent aux règles de la commissaire à
l'intégrité dans le sport d'ici avril
2023 ça arrive Pelletier et la
Commissaire je l'ai rencontré à son
bureau de Montréal
ça rêve Pelletier bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes la nouvelle
commissaire à l'intégrité dans le sport
on parle énormément de codes d'abus on
dirait depuis quelques mois on en parle
beaucoup dans les médias il y a eu
plusieurs grosses histoires et quand des
grosses fédérations est-ce qu'il y en a
plus qu'avant ou est-ce qu'on en parle
plus
je pense que c'est une bonne chose qu'on
en parle en ce moment
les questions d'abus de discrimination
de maltraitance sous toutes ses formes
évidemment pas leur place dans le sport
qu'on voit peut-être plus depuis les
derniers mois évidemment c'est vraiment
un source de mouvement de réveil de la
communauté sportive principalement par
des groupes d'athlètes qui disent c'est
assez les gens sont mieux éduquer les
gens ont une meilleure compréhension de
comment on atteint la performance avec
des belles valeurs mais il y a encore du
travail à faire dans ce sens-là je crois
vous avez reçu combien de plaintes
depuis l'ouverture du bureau alors notre
bureau va publier des statistiques sur
une base trimestrielle et on a entamé
nos opérations le 20 juin dernier
officiellement donc vous avez déjà un
premier trimestre on a un premier
trimestre de compléter et en date du 19
septembre donc à la fin de notre premier
trimestre on en était à 24 plein qui
était traités reçus par notre organisme
donc les 24 peintres reçues ce sont des
plaintes qui ont été formulées par des
athlètes qui sont membres d'organismes
qui sont financés par
qui ont signé non de ce nombre-là de 24
il n'y en aurait 16 qui ne pouvaient pas
être admissible parce qu'elle était
formulaire à l'encontre de participants
qui ne sont pas des signataires du
programme donc une grande majorité des
plaintes reçues dans les trois premiers
mois ne pouvaient pas être admissibles
ça parle d'un besoin pour un système
indépendant pour que les gens aient un
endroit sécuritaire dans lequel on
confiance vers lequel ils peuvent se
tourner pour faire part d'une situation
d'une préoccupation qu'ils ont ou de
quelque chose qui leur est arrivé donc
je crois que le chiffre qu'on parle de
24 qu'on parle de 1 qu'on parle de ça ça
parle d'un besoin le ministre symptômes
a déjà indiqué que pour obtenir le
financement fédéral les organisations
qu'elle finance devrait avoir conclu une
entente avec votre bureau je vous espoir
que les 90 organisations et concluent un
entente d'ici avril 2023 comme c'est
comme c'est prévu mais en fait on est
très encouragé par la façon dont les
choses évoluent en ce moment on a un
certain nombre d'organismes qui sont
signataires
euh mais on a beaucoup d'organisation
d'organismes pardon qui est ont déjà
signé une entente de service et qui vont
qui en fait utilisent une période de
transition pour vraiment mettre les
politiques en place assurer qu'ils ont
vraiment tous les consentements
nécessaires et qui qu'ils ont vraiment
les les choses bien prêtes pour pouvoir
utiliser nos services puis on sent on
sent le désir de collaboration je vous
dirais et on est encouragé par le fait
qu'il y en a plusieurs qu'on croit
qu'ils vont vraiment
se joindre à nous d'ici la fin de
l'année et donc potentiellement un
certain nombre c'est on l'espère d'ici
avril évidemment on a quand même des
procédures et qui sont mises en place
pour éviter un tout petit peu ce qu'on
appellerait de l'évasion le sait des
gens qui essaient de se soustraire
d'obligation
par pour quelconque raison on a établi
quelque chose qui s'appelle les
évaluations du milieu sportif et là donc
on a parlé depuis le début de l'entrevue
du traitement des plaintes et ça c'est
vraiment pour regarder des situations
spécifiques donc alors des violations
qui ont été commises par un en
particulier ce qu'on entend beaucoup
parler dans les dernières mois c'est
vraiment des situations qui sont ce
qu'on utilise c'est systémiques donc
c'est des choses qui se répètent ou qui
prévalent dans un environnement donné
les évaluations du milieu sportif vont
aller chercher la vérité comprendre le
problème essayez de comprendre les
causes sous-jacentes un problème dans un
environnement donné
essayez de d'établir les facteurs de
risque pourquoi ces situations-là se
sont produits et répétées essayez de
trouver des pistes de solutions et
formuler des recommandations dont on
parle assez récemment avec OK Canada la
victime est à l'extérieur du monde
sportif vous traitez ça comment la
position de la victime n'est pas
déterminante en soi ce qui est vraiment
important pour déterminer si votre
capable de regarder une situation c'est
la personne qui les gestes sont allés
donc la personne l'intime et si on veut
et c'est la personne qui a commis les
gestes qui est important pour nous
déterminer si on a juridiction le
contexte de où les choses se sont
passées vont avoir une certaine
influence parce qu'il faut quand même
que ce soit relié au cadre d'activités
de l'organisme mais la victime sont son
statut en elle-même est-ce que les
athlètes ou une personne complètement
dissociée de l'organisme ça ce n'est pas
déterminant en soi si vous recevez une
avalanche de plainte et vous les
ressources pour les traiter oui mais en
fait la façon que notre bureau est
constitué si on veut le bureau même le
monde mon équipe si on veut nous on est
en charge vraiment de d'établir les
processus d'établir les procédures et
les politiques et d'administrer les
plaintes mais au niveau des enquêtes
comme tel au niveau de la prise de
décision ce sont des enquêteurs
indépendants externes qui font ces
choses là et donc on a une unité
d'enquête on a une unité d'évaluateur
indépendance ce sont des experts
externes certains ont de la pratique
dans le niveau du support et certains
viennent complètement de l'extérieur du
support parce qu'on reconnaît que c'est
un besoin et donc avec ce principe
d'unité mais on est capable de nous
adapter aux besoins au volume si on veut
et à la complexité des cas et parfois
même à la spécialisation de des codes
donc certains cas qui vont demander une
expertise vraiment particulière une
doigtée particulière une clientèle
particulière alors l'unité d'enquête va
vraiment être apte à
s'adapter exactement exactement
ça fait plaisir merci à vous